there's only one thing left to do
tell your father
you tell your father everything hey
everybody it's Charlie this is gonna be
my flash episode 17 video they change
directions dramatically but they dropped
a couple really big Easter eggs and I
think that they laid a little bit of
groundwork for crisis on Infinite Earths
next year with a couple of them so we'll
explain everything as we go along if
you're new to the channel I do DC Easter
egg videos every week be sure to
subscribe to get everything
I also do weekly flash ring giveaway as
to I'll explain at the end of the video
just blanket spoiler warning for the
episode if you haven't seen it yet
because we'll be digging really deep
into it but here we go top 10 WTF in
Easter eggs the episode starts out with
Nora predictably freaking out to
reverse-flash he kind of has this weird
smile on his face too like he's kind of
expecting this he genuinely seems
interested in the things that are
happening to the timeline even though it
seems like their plan is going
completely off the rails surprise
surprise it's almost like he's got some
secret plan on the side that he has not
told Nora about and whatever that is
events are unfolding the way that he
wants them to or he's just looking for
opportunities to exploit this new
timeline that's being created because
grace has come back to present either
way Sherlock wells was correct when he
said that reverse-flash has been
manipulating Nora this whole time to
suit his own ends
number 9 future grace explains
everything to oralin in present day
about how she's come back in time she
stole eobard thawne's time ship so that
they could complete their mission and
eliminate every single metahuman on
earth both of them chew every last piece
of scenery that they're in but the best
thing about this was the way that Chris
Klein's face was frozen as if he were
horrified and confused at the same time
it was just hilarious to watch him try
to swallow everything that grace was
trying to tell him like he couldn't
believe it so I think they did a good
job at the episode of just kind of
pushing their storyline along to its
logical conclusion and not belaboring
that for another episode or two but
number 8 the stark Ives this is actually
just a trove of Easter eggs designed to
make you pause the episode and look in
the background at all the objects from
previous seasons I'm trying to remember
where this gun was from I think this is
season 1 the helmet in the background
the red one is the one that Barry wore
in the pilot episode when they were
trying to test his speed for the first
time on the runway on the Feres air
Greenland
Runway but when elongated man says this
looks like a vacuum cleaner it's
actually a prop that they used during a
Captain Cold episode in season 1 it
literally does look just like a vacuum
cleaner and if you don't remember this
giant gun over on the right side here
this is sabotage gun that they were
using to try and slice him up all over
time-space so that the time wave
wouldn't affect him and he would
continue to exist even if they changed
the timeline this is the season 4 suit
here there's a Doctor Who Easter Egg on
the reverse flashes times fear plans
that says neutron flows can't be
reversed it's perverse the polarity of
the neutron flow which is a third doctor
saying this is obviously reverse flashes
wheelchair his eyeglasses I can't
remember the last time we saw this but
this is a biography for that earth 1eu
Bart Thawne reverse-flash the reason why
they're alerted and they go there is is
because Sherlock Wells had been digging
around looking for stuff he goes back a
couple times that's why iris confronted
him later in the episode have you been
going back there all weekend long yes
I've been searching for something I
won't stop until I'm done
7 q up operation Shazam I know everybody
has so many questions about this Easter
Egg because there's like wait a minute
does Shazam exist in this universe
obviously there's the music app that's
also named Shazam but you don't say the
word Shazam out loud in a DC TV show
then draw a lightning bolt without
clearly intending on referencing the
comic book Shazam I don't want to say
this completely canonized as Shazam to
the DC TV universe but it's possible
that he exists it's a bit of 50-50
because the writers and the producers
could always say no no no you know
winking for behind the camera we were
just referencing the smartphone app you
know just being as sarcastic as possible
of course they're referencing the comic
book Shazam they just used this moment
to confirm that grace cicada stole
reverse flashes times fear from the
future we don't know how she stole it
but presumably the stark Ives exists in
the future and she just broke her way in
and took it unless she's also working
with perverse flash but that almost
seems like it would be a little too
twisty I'm not quite ready to believe
that yet but we've only started learning
the truth of what's been going on in the
future between Nora and reverse flash so
we'll see if there's any more evidence
that reverse flash is somehow
manipulating grace in the future as well
sakes there was a really big lost
reference not Penny's boat there's sort
of a competing timelines reference
because of what's happening on the flash
with the different timelines of this
season it gets even more meta
when elongated man gets the waiters name
wrong he says Larry no it's Jason that's
a reference to the time loop episode at
jitters where Nora kept changing things
over and over and over again at the end
of that episode Barry explained that the
more Nora tried to change the timeline
the more that reality represented by the
coffee cup which started to crack and
things would permanently started to
change in a really unpredictable way one
of those things was the Larry waiter
turning into Jason so obviously that's
also big-picture stuff laying groundwork
for crisis on Infinite Earths so coffee
cup explainer changing the timeline too
much breaking reality then some bigger
reverse flash Easter eggs that I'll talk
about in a second just because they're
way lower on my list here number five
was all of elongated man spider-man
jokes he was on fire when it came to
Easter eggs and references this week I
Peter Parker her maybe she can get
bitten by something radioactive do you
think that she'd make a good spider
person and then he even makes the
spider-man swift motion Cisco says
spider person later in the episode maybe
that's their copyright safe version of a
spider-man reference I don't know why
they would get in trouble for saying
spider-man in an episode because they've
said Hulk out loud they said Marvel out
loud so Marvel Comics does exist inside
the world of the flash number four was
Nora being psychically connected to
grace that was a bit of a WTF moment
like wait a minute
where did this come from I guess the way
they explained it is is that it's only
happening in the future so the reason
why we haven't seen this before is
because future Grace just came back to
present-day
so it has something to do with what
happened when Nora went into her mind
I'm sure they'll find a way to pay that
off by the end of the season because you
can now very clearly see how her story
is a parallel for Nora's story because
they're both from the future so
defeating Grace will probably be
something that Nora does by the end of
the season as opposed to Barry three was
reverse flashes video diary so this is
the another big Easter egg laying
groundwork for crisis on Infinite Earths
so Sherlock wells finds what is video
log number 247 although I think that
there are probably a bunch of video logs
on that little chip device but it's
season one reverse flash when he was
still pretending to be eobard thawne
during the events of that season
creating the time language code that he
was using to record all the timeline
changes the reason why it's important is
is because he calls that the source code
of the multiverse which is a big Jack
Kirby fourth world
source wall reference if you're not
familiar with the New Gods comics the
source started out as one thing and they
kind of changed things as the comics
have gone along but originally it was
the source of all the new God's power
that includes Darkseid all the forces of
apocalypse hi father
Orion all the people that lived on new
Genesis more recently what DC has done
during the rebirth era is that they said
that the source wall was actually built
to protect this multiverse from what was
outside much bigger dangers big
celestial level creatures so the reason
why I think this is important for crisis
on Infinite Earths is is because they're
talking about cracking reality with all
the timeline changes the references to
the source code I think that they're
gonna push into some of those ideas for
crisis on Infinite Earths and it will be
the path through which the anti-monitor
enters our multiverse to future grace
kills cicada based on their interactions
and scenes early in the episode I think
this is a fairly predictable outcome and
I'm kind of glad that they didn't
stretch it out for a couple more
episodes they were always headed in this
direction why not just get it over with
and let her be the big bad for the next
big arc of the show if you were confused
about how Grace's powers work in the
episode there was also a Caitlyn explain
her at the end where they sort of
clarified why she was able to stop Cisco
from vibing through his portal she can
just control the dark matter in other
people so in a limited way she can
control them so I think they just wanted
to provide an upgrade threat that would
be able to steamroll them before they
figure things out number one though they
waited till like the last three minutes
of the episode for Sherlock wells to out
nor a secret to the group they really
want to leave it to that next episode to
explain what's going on but based on his
explanation it's reverse-flash that's
been manipulating the timeline via Nora
to his own purposes this entire time
Nora has been a little more altruistic
she wants to save her dad so I think
she's proven herself to be pretty
gullible this season so it's not so
far-fetched that she would just swallow
anything that he would say claiming that
he is the smartest speedster it was even
a line of dialogue a little while ago
where he said I am the only speedster
who understands what's going on so of
course Nora would do whatever you said
but they threw in the pipeline prison
remember she's connected to grace
psychically so they're gonna have to let
her out anyway to defeat grace bonus WTF
moment though the next episode isn't for
another month that's right we have to
wait for weeks for the Godspeed
episode of the flash I will do a trailer
video interestingly an F though even
though the episode is titled Godspeed
and we've seen him behind the scenes he
is nowhere to be found in the trailer
footage that they released so maybe
there'll be an extended trailer where
they have a little bit extra footage but
no worries I'll post that episode
tomorrow also name a new flash ring
giveaway winner when I post that so
click here for my season 5
god speed teaser just explain what's
going on with him and click here for all
my brand new Avengers and game trailer
Easter eggs from the alternate versions
of the trailers thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
you